اعتاد الفرنسيون وتحديدا الباريسيون على
التجمع وعلى تنظيم مظاهرات كل سبت تقريبا
منذ بدات الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه ونحن
الان في هذه المظاهره قلب باريس يلاحظ
بانها تقترن زمنيا مع الاعياد ورغم ذلك
خرج الفرنسيون لكي يعبروا عن دعمهم
وتضامنهم وتنديد بالحرب المستمره منذ اكثر
من 75 يوما نلاحظ هذه الاعداد في قلب
باريس رغم كما قلت الاعياد وفتره الاعياد
ما يرفعه هؤلاء من شعارات يمكن تلخيصها
مريم في انهم اولا التضامن مع سكان غزه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني الادانه والشجب القويين
لاسرائيل
ولقوى الغربيه التي تدعم اسرائيل وايضا
ادانه وشجب
لمجلس الامن الذي اخفق في فرض
يعني وقف اطلاق النار بشكل تام وسريع
وطبعا طبعا ادانه ايضا لاستمرار سكوت
المجتمع الدولي على المجازر التي ترتكبها
اسرائيل في هذه الاعلام في هذه الشعارات
في هذه الكلمات ايضا كنا استمعنا قبل قليل
الى شهاده حيه عبر الفيديو كونفرنس من من
غزه تحديدا
من بلده لاهيه حيث تحدثت فلسطينيه باللغه
الفرنسيه عن الماسات وعن المعاناه
التي يعيشها الفلسطينيون في غزه هذه
الاعلام الفلسطينيه تلاحظين ايضا مريم ان
عدد كبير من الفرنسيين الاصليين الذين
اذكر بان الراي العام الفرنسي تغير منذ
الاسبوع الثاني من الحرب وهذا التغير ربما
هو الذي اثر مريم في وجهه نظر الحكومه
الفرنسيه كما تعلمين في البدايه كان هناك
موقفا
فرنسيا حسب على انه مؤيد لنتنياهو لكن في
المده الاخيره تغيرت الامور ان صح التعبير
واصبحت فرنسا تطالب بوقف اطلاق النار
وتطالب بعدم استهداف
المدنيين نحن اذا بصدد راي عام
فرنسي مؤيد للشعب الفلسطيني ومطالب بوقف
الحرب على سكان غزه وعلى هذه
المجازر يلاحظ ايضا مريم انه ايضا كل
الفرنسيين يقولون نحن كلنا فلسطينيون
وهناك ايضا مجموعه من الاطباء الذين حضروا
هنا دعما لسلك الطبي في غزه والمستشفيات
التي نعلم بانها جميعا خرجت بنسبه ك
عن الخدمه وهناك ايضا من تحدث ايضا تضامنا
مع الصحفيين الذين قتلوا وعائلاتهم وهناك
كانت شهاده قويه من احدى النقابات
الفرنسيه التي تدافع عن حقوق الصحفيين
نواصل اذا متابعه هذه الاجواء في هذه
المظاهره في باريس والكلمات التي تلقى
وهنا الان حديث حتى ان اسرائيل تستهدف
الكنائس في غزه نحن اذا ب صدد يعني ادانه
واضحه لما تقوم به اسرائيل حاليا في غزه
ويقولون بان لا يجب على الاعلام الفرنسي
ان يقدم للجمهور الفرنسي هذه الحرب على
انها حرب بين الاديان بين الاسلام
والمسيحيه
و نترككم هذه اللحظات مع مريم مع هذه
الاجواء وهذه
الاعلام من الواضح مريم لو تقارنين
بدايه الموقف الفرنسي مثل هذه المظاهرات
في البدايه عندما بدا العدوان الاسرائيلي
على غزه لم يكن مرخص بها لان السلطات
الفرنسيه تقول لا تريد ان تجلب النزاع الى
داخل الاراضي الفرنسيه لكن شيئا فشيئا
اضطرت الحكومه لكي تقبل بمثل هذه
المظاهرات عندما شاهدت ان العديد من
المظاهرات خرجت في بعض الاحيان رغم
الاجراءات الامنيه ورغم محاوله فرض رجال
الامن مثلا طوق على فضاءات التجمع وحتى
الذهاب الى ابعد من ذلك بفرض غرات غرامات
على كل من ياتي ويخرق النظام تنظيم هذه
المظاهرات اليوم من الواضح ان هذه
المظاهرات بد لها اثر واضح في الموقف
الفرنسي على المستوى البرلماني بحيث اصبحت
الحكومه الفرنسيه الان الى حد ما يمكن
القول تميل
لصالح القضيه الفلسطينيه الابرز ربما مريم
هو عندما يصدح هؤلاء
بان فلسطين ستنتصر يقولونها باللغه
الفرنسيه ساحاول مع الزميل المصور عماد
التحرك الان لزاويه اخرى من هذا التجمع
اذكر بان في فرنسا اليوم مريم اكثر من
مظاهره لعل اكبرها ربما هي في مدينه
ستراسبورغ شرق فرنسا وايضا مدينه ران ران
التي يمكن القول بانها حطمت الرقم القياسي
لا يكاد يمر اسبوع من دون ان تشهد هذه
المدينه مظاهره مؤيده لغزه ولشعب
الفلسطيني وللطالب بوقف اطلاق النار الان
نسمع اصوات اخرى وخطاب اخ خطابات اخرى
تدين هذه المحاولات التي تريد بعض وسائل
الاعلام الفرنسيه ان تظهر بان هذه
المظاهرات هي معاديه للساميه بينما هؤلاء
يقولون نحن لا مشكله لدينا مع الساميه
مشكلتنا هي مع الصهيونيه ومع الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يقوم بقتل الابرياء
والمدنيين دعيني في
l'ul de la manifestation d'aujourd'hui
c'est gaza au secours puisque on en est
plus de 20000 desc probablement beaucoup
plus dans la rit donc cr notre cr notre
colc
don puis aussi don des outils des armes
ceux qui veulent dans la soci civile
lutter pour la justice en palestine et
une de ces armes la principale peut qui
nous offerte ici dans nos pays
c'est يقول باختصار شديد بان هذه المظاهره
شعارها غزه النجده غزه الانقاذ ويقول بان
هذه المظاهره هي في الحقيقه من نوع
المظاهرات التي تطالب بوقف الحرب
الفلسطينيين ويقول بان نريد ان تكون لدينا
وسائل من اجل الدفاع عن سكان غزه ومن بين
هذه الوسائل هي مقاطعه اسرائيل على حد
تعبيره اذا مريم كما تلاحظين باختصار شديد
المظاهره مستمره الكلمات مستمره تلاحظين
الحضور اللافت للكوفيه الفلسطينيه وللعلم
الفلسطيني وايضا تلاحظين ولا شك هذه ال
الصور صور الضحايا الاطفال والمدنيين
والسكان الذين قضوا في هذه الحرب التي
تشنها اسرائيل منذ حوالي
76 يوما في غزه هذهه اذا اجواء هذه
المظاهره في قلب باريس اذكر بان هناك
مظاهرات ايضا في مدن فرنسيه اخرى لا يزال
الشارع الفرنسي كل اسبوع كل نهايه اسبوع
يعبر عن دعمه لغزه وايضا لمعارضته
وللتنديد بهذه الحرب وايضا تنديده ب
السكوت الدولي على المجازر التي ترتكب